good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the
toast hey happy Wednesday happy
Wednesday worst day ever yesterday was
the worst day ever I don't even know how
to function and like do this job I've
actually never had a harder time doing
my job in my entire life I felt
literally embarrassed of yesterday's
episode like I yesterday was literally
the worst day we did the episode and I
think in the morning given like the time
difference we don't get news here about
what's going on in Israel until and when
we wrapped and really just tried to do
like a nice funny show like well also
talking about what's going on is just
kind of the way that we would talk like
normally the way if we were hanging out
um and I felt like when I woke up in the
morning I was feeling a little more
hopeful hopeful and and feeling like you
know it's our job to bring light and
that's what we're going to do today so
we did our show and then we just got up
and checked our phones
and I literally felt like embarrassed to
have put out that episode like given
what I had read after after after we
wrapped I I literally was humiliated
like I wasn't humiliated but I just felt
stupid like I I I didn't even promote
yesterday's episode I don't I don't know
how to function like for real I I agree
so after the episode we read about the
babies there are no words there are no
words and then in like I feel like in
that moment like I I I'm a different
person since that and then so looking
back at the episode I'm like how did I
know how but then throughout yesterday
like we've just been talking honestly
talking to your people is com so
comforting right now and I've that I go
through like highs and lows but I saw a
quote this morning that makes me feel
very strongly about us doing what we do
and that we have to keep doing it so let
me find my my Instagram quote card
that's buoying me that's my new favorite
word cuz I need to be I need to be booed
right now okay I love that word it's
kind of like tethered right yeah but
like for the ocean for the ocean um like
there are very few things buoying me
right now I'm so glad you I love the
word buoying you read your quote this is
my quote from my new favorite Instagram
account Lee Kern he wrote on the movie
Borat he's so funny and he's so pro
Israel and you need to follow him he do
have morning Lee Kar 13 love laughter
and inspiration are life support for the
human soul do your best to keep people's
spirits up that doesn't mean we pretend
all is amazing but help keep your fellow
Jews from slipping into trauma and
paralysis we love each other we will
emerge on the other side oh my God
everything Lee Kern's posts makes me cry
and there also so there's other ones
that are so [__] funny and that's
what we have to do that's our job I said
to you yesterday we all have our role to
play in the war to come oh my God Jackie
pulled that Game of Thrones card out of
her ass and like I've been thinking
about it non-stop say it again we all
have our role to play in the war to come
we are at War we have a few roles to
play and one of them is to help people's
Souls another one is to be so proudly
Zionist to share information to share
the truth to everything that we're doing
so as much as like you want to sink
we're doing our part yes and part of
that is the light and it it doesn't mean
and we're I'm happy to go in and out of
talking about Israel right now because
like that's what our day has been that's
what our stream of Consciousness is like
and also we kind of just have been
sitting around like reading the news
also like reading everyone's garbage
post on Instagram the social media I
can't stop talking about it I I feel
conflicted cuz it's so unimportant but
like it is it is important it's
important and I just know everyone who
listens to our show is sitting around
doing the same thing sending everyone's
post to their group chat like what is
this person actually saying what does
this person actually stand for and we're
having those conversations on this show
so um things that are booing us I love
that um what's booing me right now well
first of all I went yesterday to a pro
Israel rally which honestly like I I'm
like ashamed to admit like I was
terrified to go to remember I was I was
sitting with you yesterday and I got
like really nauseous I think like I was
scared like I think that's what my
nausea was from um because the the other
side we've seen they're so violent and
they're cheering on what happened
they're holding up swas to us like these
are not people who who want me walking
around being proud lewish so I really
was terrified and shout out to my friend
moti onari who posts the he's literally
the best Instagram account another
Instagram account that you everyone
should follow m m o onari he's texting
me he's like we're going like he's like
stop I'm like okay okay we're going I
said this morning like should we do our
show like The Fast Five Instagram
accounts you need to unfollow and five
that you need to follow so let's
throughout just drop ones that you
should follow and sure one I'm loving
that is incredibly graphic but like you
said like this is not time for trigger
warnings this is not time to protect
yourself like this is happening to real
people and unless you see it you won't
believe it 40 babies do you know how
many people are m 40 babies is a Zionist
propaganda lie really I saw a picture
what's so crazy first of all they had to
live it so we have to watch it we have
to know what happened what's so crazy is
all the footage that's coming out was
taken by Hamas because they're like so
proud of what they did and the world
can't look away because look it's right
there they're showing us that's the one
thing where Israel did not put out like
the pictures explicitly they're all kind
of blurred and so people are doubting
that it happened they're saying that
it's like Zionist propaganda and so it's
like imagine if Hamas didn't take all
those videos you wouldn't no no no
people would not believe that this
happened and they would say that Israel
is lying so on the one hand it's like
it's so awful that they're like
broadcasting and live streaming what
they did but on the other hand like
thank God you guys wouldn't believe it
so in not the toasters cuz the toaster
are good people oh yeah by the way when
we I'm so angry and keep saying you guys
like yesterday I was just like recording
you guys you guys I'm not talking to
like our community that is the best
community on the internet I've ever been
so proud to do what we do like let's do
cam toast again like we've got to get
together we've got to get together um
but the account that I was referring to
was called Black and Jewish Unity it's
by far my favorite account um especially
given that yesterday or maybe even the
day before yester yesterday like the
official black lives matter organization
that so many of us rallied behind and
raised money for and were were happy to
to support especially within the Jewish
Community who has historically stood up
for civil rights um to see them come out
with a statement for all of their
chapters that they stand with Palestine
like was
so vile and so
disgusting and so black and Jewish unity
and and I know that doesn't represent a
lot of the black community so I think
that account is really great black and
Jewish Unity Mo anari too Nate buzz like
there's really good people doing good
work and I we should you know leverage
our platform to to promote them to
promote them Liz wood she's got the
celebrity angle on not SK not fat killer
content Violet Benson killer content
I've been enjoying following bar Rafael
since
yesterday that's booing me another thing
booing me is this chat so we were put in
um in this chat uh yesterday I don't
know who organized it but just with like
a lot of infl influential celebrities
influencers who support Israel like what
can we do how can we raise money it's
just kind of this Coalition if you will
think tank and it is first of all just
like seeing who joins like I'm I'm still
me you know like seeing you know
celebrities phone numbers like I'm
obsessed like that is booing me and just
being around like-minded people and
that's why going to the rally yesterday
I'm sorry my thoughts are all over the
place I was so scared like seriously
petrified and it was amazing oh my God
the
sheer number of people the something
about the pro is is movement is you know
it's always like your grandpa like it's
always like the old people you see in sh
who have lived long enough to know why
the state of Israel is so important
there's never really like a galvanized
youth movement and this rally yesterday
was literally my high school reunion
like it was just so amazing to see so
many young people so many people and
enormous shout out like I felt so safe I
didn't even I was not looking over my
shoulder for one second everyone was
metal detected it took forever to get in
metal detected cops everywhere like huge
shout out to the NYPD like there was
barricades and droves of police like I
just felt so safe um and uja was the
organization organization that put it on
and I think paid for all that security
so I felt really great and it was just
like so when you live in the internet
which I do my screen time I can't even
imagine what it is this week yeah I'm
thinking the same thing it's just so
easy to forget that like there are
normal people and there are good people
and there are allies and they're they're
and it was I think I read somewhere it
was 12,000 people wow it took me about
30 minutes to walk out the governor was
there the mayor was there the UN
Ambassador for Israel was there
everybody spoke everybody was singing
like it was just it it was fabulous so
like that's a high yeah but like my
friends Jewish I mean not Jewish friends
just being like how are you doing like
what can I do the only way to describe
it is like highs and lows
yeah because I don't know I don't know
either but just every like I feel like
people especially influencers like don't
necessarily post and I felt this way
sometimes too because it's like I don't
have anything new to say and I don't
know what to say so I'm I'm not going to
say anything but like
just letting people know where you stand
on the sign of Human Rights like means
so much the bar is so low the bar is so
low yeah I can't meet it people can't
meet it and now all of a sudden now all
of a sudden you can't be taking up space
with your voice it used to be that your
silence was violence I I guess no longer
now silence is necessary in the face of
evil you should be silent yeah that's
what I'm seeing and I don't get it why
did Silence stop being like I don't know
I think when when the violence was
targeted in Jews that's when silence was
okay no stop no like popular culture and
rhetoric is so frustrating right now I
can't in our you know in our sisters
chats and we're like chatting with you
know people we we know our allies other
influencers we just keep screenshotting
and being like are you f imagine
releasing a statement on this entire and
I'm going to call out Reese
[__] Witherspoon releasing a
statement on this entire Saga and not
once in your statement is the word
Israel or the word Hamas
or the Jew manipulating language so much
to mark yourself as safe from like any
sort of backlash like are you [__]
serious when I look at someone like
Reese Witherspoon who is like a who's a
mom but also has like a really big
community of moms and G how can you read
about the breast milk shortage so many
mothers have been slaughtered that
there's not enough breast milk in the
country for their babies like how can
you read that and put together some
[__] statement like seriously [__]
you [__] you yeah seriously [__] you
every one like doing back flips and back
hands Springs mental gymnastics to no
not mental veral verbal or gynastics to
Mark what's the word for writing written
sure okay whatever I thought that was a
better word orated that's speaking um to
Mark themselves safe they spoke out hi I
care but you don't care about [__] who
do you care about you care who do you
care about
seriously it's so disappointing so many
spineless people but we always knew the
celebrities they [__] suck I know
they [__] suck and to put so much and
and this is maybe a moment in my life
where I need to reevaluate seriously
like how much emphasis and like and love
and support like I give to other people
yeah celebrities like it's and I know
she will never but like it's literally
gutting me that Taylor Swift hasn't said
anything like this I'm liter gonna cry
like it's so stupid why am I crying like
this is someone I admire so much and
like I put so much of my my heart into
like it's so stupid like I really need
to
reevaluate I mean I've been saying that
but yeah no it's like embarrassing yeah
and like I know she'll never she doesn't
speak out about anything but this is
unlike anything that has ever happened
like in our lifetimes
in this isn't just like another social
issue where you like post a graphic and
check a box like and and by the way it's
only going to get worse and that's
another thing that's just so Haring like
this is just the beginning of it like
Israel has yet to retaliate so so many
people are going to die so many people
are going to die and in America it's
like this dumb war of of statements dumb
war of statements and it's like you know
there's bad on both
sides no that's not what it is this is
good versus evil Israel is going to
defend itself now and people are going
to die and Israel is going to go out of
their way to make sure there's a few
civilian casualties as possible they
from the before they started dropping
bombs they said women children civilians
the out get the out go north there's two
borders outside of Gaza people don't
understand this let talk about this Gaz
let's talk about this the Gaza Strip
borders Israel on one side where that's
how they got into Massacre slaughterfest
rape Fest 2023 and they also in the
South border Egypt if they want to get
out of Gaza go to Egypt oh they can't
Jackie why Palestinians living in Gaza
are not allowed into Egypt why Claudia I
don't know why doesn't somebody somebody
ask Egypt why where's Egypt you guys
bring up Egypt why don't you instead of
well I don't support that Israeli
government what about Egypt where the
[__] are you at no and for and by the
way because of course Israel is not
going to let those people in right now
because when they let those people in
you saw what happened and by the way for
many years you were allowed to there
wasn't like a big um border between
Israel and Gaza like you could roam
freely and you know what happened people
roamed freely with bombs on their chests
and they blew up a sabaro pizza shop and
they blew up buses
so so that's why we are where we are now
where you can't just freely roam in no
and there's a checkpoint where you have
to get searched so that you don't enter
with weapons
like there's history there it's not this
way for no reason Israel has been so
[__] patient with these monsters yeah
they're out of time for days they're
still telling people to go if if Hamas
doesn't let the women and children go
and they still want to plant their
children in front of their rocket
launchers and the rocket launchers need
to be bombed those deaths are on Hamas
100% like I I think everybody everywhere
can acknowledge and feel for innocent
Palestinians living in Gaza like for
real and and to put any blame on what's
going to happen to them on Israel is
shameful and anti-semitic because
anything that happens to an innocent
person in Gaza is at the sole
responsibility of their elected
officials and their elected officials
their government is Hamas a terrorist
organization whose Charter says we will
not be happy we will not sleep
peacefully until every Jew is eradicated
we will not be happy until Israel is
completely wiped off the mouth map and
once we do that our next our next victim
America right so if if if caring about
people in the Middle East is not
something you're capable
of well first of all look Inward and
second of all maybe you can care when
it's about you and it already is about
you 12 I I heard this morning on the
news I don't know if this number is
verified 12 of the 150 people captured
and living in Gaza are um American
hostages American hostages and 14 of the
deaths are Amer citizens there are
Germans there there are Mexicans there
there are nepales people there like I I
don't know what I could possibly say to
make people care and make people see
what's going on but this impacts all of
us like it really does so if you can't
you know lift an arm to give a [__]
about Jews maybe you'll care about a
fellow American I don't know though also
another weak statement I I
support Israel and I support a pre
Palestine you guys I hate so does Israel
I hate to be the one to tell you this
but when they chant free Palestine from
The River To The Sea Palestine will be
free that is the land of Israel so you
cannot have a Jewish State and a free
Palestine we we've been trying we would
love that but that doesn't work for them
so you can't there's no both sides here
there's that's just the end of it like
there's no both sides here please like
take a stand something scared people are
of the backlash and we've heard that
like a lot of you know managers
publicists whatever are telling their
clients don't say anything even if they
want to post something they're like
don't post anything it's insane and I
guess if you weren't going to post
anything so stop posting your regular
life stop posting your regular life stop
posting your ads because I haven't
noticed any like I only noticed the
influencers who are posting their
regular life I'm like oh but you didn't
post anything about this but if you
haven't posted anything I haven't not
like you're flying under the radar yeah
and that's fine and that's fine but to
go on like so unabashedly like going you
know flying around going to parties like
it's insane posting your ads yeah though
I do have an ad today and I'm going to
be posting in it yeah why should we be
punished no I'll get the money and I'll
donate a tel no any Brands who want to
work with me I'm feeling all incoming
offers I will be donating a Tiel so yeah
why would I leave that on the table for
sure why is Hamas going to win win take
my money no literally no I don't think
so not today Hamas not
today other things booing me oh yes my
book of course last night this made me
cry and a to like so many toasters are
sending me pictures of their kids with
my book I sent this picture in the chat
of um this little redheaded girl holding
the book she literally was the camper
she's you and the toaster was like she
thinks the book is about her stop oh my
God Claudia I was beside myself like
100% I don't know why it just like
struck me just cuz the book is like it's
so pure and just like I don't know I it
was the cutest thing I ever saw it is
about her I told her I'm like tell her
the book is about her she is the camer
redhead representation matters no it
really does like she said she doesn't
really like see red redheads aren't
usually like the main characters we've
got a few you know we have parents H and
Annie um but even they had to split
screen time it was two redheads played
by one actress they could representation
yeah um and it just like warned my heart
people are sending me all of these
pictures with the book their kids are
loving it the book is sold out
everywhere so I don't really have a lot
of promotion to do today it will be back
in stock on Thursday so maybe I'll do a
fresh launch on Friday you know yeah for
sure let's let's regroup on Friday like
let's go so [__] hard on Friday yeah
for the book when there's more in stock
I can't believe it's sold out everywhere
like I didn't think I okay okay Janette
MCC I didn't like when I placed my first
order of books like that's how many I
thought I would sell in yeah over time
so I never thought I would run out on
launch week which is cool but it's not
even like good you know cuz it's
annoying that people can't get the book
that they want um but there are still
copies available Talk Shop live those
are the sign bookplate copies I'll be
doing Talk Shop live tonight we'll also
be running a drive for friends of the
IDF through talk shop live so we'll just
be like girly swirlies ding about the
book doing our thing and that will just
be fun and maybe it will be booing for
some for sure and I think by the way
like the reason why that made you choke
up I think we're all just like so many
in Israel the the majority of the
victims of violence and terrorism are
kids yeah so whether you're a mom or not
you're just like looking at kids now
like these precious Souls precious Souls
who at every cost need to be protected
yeah that's why so it's for the kids
it's for the kids it's the best book
ever like and I heard everybody talking
about what happen at the lake everyone's
talking about it everyone's talking
about it you have to get the book no
spoilers here so thank you to everyone
who's been so supportive the toaster are
the best community my DMs are flooded
with love and support and I've read them
all I can't
get like I haven't responded to all them
but I see them and it means so so much
to us oh my God I met a thousand
toasters I literally was like I felt
like the president like no you should
have gotten up in given speech I I was a
little offended I wasn't asked to sing
hatikva my favorite song that I slay so
hard Olivia literally asked me last
night to send her a video of myself
saying a haa but like I'm I was a little
horse I don't want to do it who saying
it nobody or maybe I didn't stay for the
entire thing so maybe like at the end
somebody's saying it okay maybe on the
next one the yeah I'm available I love
the Israeli Nation Israel national
anthem it's the best song it
is are you gonna do it it's honestly
would make me cry no and honestly I
literally I want to wait for the proper
stage I can't ever hear this song
without crying especially not today so
no um we're not here to depress you
we're you're already depressed yeah yeah
we're going to try to buoy we've got
some random [__] stories certain
celebrities are booing me right now yeah
and certain celebrities I'll never speak
of again yeah I think we all know who
they are like they need not be named
yeah we all know so without further Ado
I guess did you here I just want to feel
stupid again you know no I don't feel
stupid like it's important it is it is
it is to bring light and laughter and
that's so the essence of the Jewish
people like they're killing us and we're
dancing no I'm liter I saw a video of
like a wedding in Israel I know where n
the bride and groom had come so and none
of the guest could come so just random
Israelis Jews were there celebrating
dancing with them like they gave them a
wedding it was so sweet it was so sweet
like that's what we have to do we have
to live we do we do we do it's hard but
that's what we do so we're going to do
what we D and here are the fast SI
stories that you most certainly don't
need to know but you're gonna you're
gonna today's episode is brought to you
by stamps.com the Holiday Rush means
more mailing and shipping for your
business but it doesn't have to mean
more stress stamps.com has been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money for 25 years and it can help you
get ready for the holiday ramp up all
you need is stamps.com premium rates for
all your postage needs thank you
stamps.com for letting us reminding us
that that season is upon us and that
season is fabulous but it's also very
stressful especially if you own a
business and with stamps.com you have
your own personal post office wherever
you go all you need is a computer and a
printer and they'll even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
taking care of orders on the go is even
easier with the stamps.com mobile app if
you need to arrange a pickup you can
easily schedule it through the
stamps.com dashboard you're basically
getting premium discounts and supplies
at your fingertips so if you're running
low you can order shipping and mailing
supplies labels even printers from their
supply store you're getting huge
discounts up to $84 4% off USPS and UPS
rates to help your bottom line and they
automatically tell you the cheapest and
fastest shipping op options for your
order for 25 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over a million
businesses so get your business ready
for the holiday rush and get started
with stamps.com today sign up with promo
code toast for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts are
required all you have to do is go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page enter code toast and get
access to the USPS and PS services that
you need right from your computer
anytime day or night there's no lines
there's no traffic and there's no
waiting so again go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and enter code toast which is T
O A St today's episode is also brought
to you by Skylight frames ever miss your
loved ones when you aren't together cuz
I know I do cuz my sisters hate me and
they move to Florida here's a gift that
brings everyone together no matter how
far apart you are the Skylight frame so
the Skylight Fame frame is a great gifts
for parents it is a touchscreen photo
frame that your whole family can email
photos to and they will appear in
seconds you get to share your favorite
moments with the people that matter most
so it's a great gift for anyone with a
birthday coming up someone who just had
a baby grandparents it really is a great
great gift for grandparents because even
though it's digital is extremely simple
to set up and to continually send photos
to so even if you're not you know the
most technologically advanced maybe
you're not you know tury the IT
department you can still handle a
skylight frame and it looks like a real
photo frame so it add a beautiful touch
to your home and it can hold thousands
of photos that will continuously rotate
throughout the day and bring daily Joy
so they have a gorgeous touchcreen it
comes in two sizes the original 10-in
and a new 15in Gallery frame you can
swipe through photos with your finger
you can tap it to give a little like and
it'll let that person know that you
liked it they have 100% satisfaction
guaranteed so if you don't love your
Skylight they will offer you a full
refund time goes fast staying in touch
with those we love is more important
than ever and now the Skylight frame
makes it easy and fun as a special offer
for our listeners you can get $15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylightframe.com
toast that'll get you $15 off your
purchase at Skylight frame so just go to
skylightframe.com toast that's Sky l i g
HT F
r.com toast skylightframe.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by zip recruiter right now let's give a
shout out to all the people whose job it
is to hire from the small business
owners growing their team to the HR
directors hiring hundreds Across the
Nation you have one of the toughest
toughest jobs there is but what if I
were to tell you that there was
something that can make your whole
hiring process faster and easier it's
zip recruiter and right now you can try
it for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com toast so instead of you
doing all the hiring work zi recruiter
works for you once you post your job on
zip recruiter it sends it to over a 100
job sites so you're reaching more of the
right people zip recruiter's powerful
technology scans thousands of rums for
you to identify people whose skills at
experience match your job and because
you've got a busy schedule they're
saving you time their smart technology
finds and sends you the available great
matches for your job and once you review
the list of the most qualified
candidates for your job you can easily
invite your top choices to apply so
they're more likely to apply sooner so
Hiring Heroes let us help you you do so
much it's our turn to help you let zip
recruiter make your life and your job
easier four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day see for
yourself and go to our exclusive link
ziprecruiter.com toast to try zi
recruiter for free so again that's zip
recruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com
toast help you find the right people for
your job it can be really hard it's a
really hering process whatever you're
looking for they cover a wide span of
candidates they have got you covered it
is the best and most efficient way to
find the right candidate so again
ziprecruiter.com toast zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire we also have deer
toasters today and when I tell you I was
chucklin I was chucklin when I was
reading them oh good you have the iPad
so I do I do I'm taking my sweet time oh
sure yeah yeah yeah no rush our first
story is actually some celeb news that
would have made the Fast Five if the
world wasn't set on fire um by Hama on
Saturday so Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner
have reached a custody agreement that's
it's nice it's nice and they're speaking
out after their successful mediation and
they vow to be great co-parents Joe and
Sophie are ready to put their tumultuous
custody battle behind them and focus on
amicably raising their young daughters
the former couple released a joint
statement about their c-par Dynamic just
hours after reaching a temporary custody
agreement for their three-year-old and
one-year-old quote after a productive
and successful mediation we have agreed
that the children will spend equally in
loving home spend time and equally
loving homes in both the US and the UK
we look forward to being great
co-parents I mean right this was just
like a a shocking turn of events because
it's been so bad and I think when we all
saw the lawsuit and then the custody we
were reading it and we were like this is
something that's going to go on forever
and it's going to get really messy so
they mediated one time we all saw the
pictures of Sophie leaving and we love
that do you think that the events of
this weekend maybe put things into
perspective for
them I don't know how involved you know
Joe and Sophie are in global issues like
I don't know I don't I just feel like it
it it could have and for some people it
would have maybe not that maybe they
were like definitely possible that this
could have imped wow you know what like
let's do what's best
we're right let's put like you love them
I love them let's split time with them
like we are so grateful and blessed
honestly that's an amazing call I think
it's entirely possible because like we
were saying like anyone with a child I
mean anyone but anyone with a child
specifically like
is looking at them differently today
yeah and I feel like we were saying how
this is was getting so nasty like it was
going to be one mediation of many and if
they could even mediate they would
probably go to court they would courte
for January and all of a sudden it's
good I mean that would be a nice thing I
don't know I feel like for some people
that would have happened I don't know
them at like personally so I don't know
if that's what it is but I don't think
it's out of the realm of possibility me
neither that's a nice way to look at it
mhm I'm I'm glad they worked this out
honestly I have not enjoyed talking
about the demise of this marriage in
this family like it's actually really
sad yeah so they were able to work it
out across the pond so it's good I
wonder where in the US they'll live
hopefully New York it's just it's so
much closer it's so much closer it's
it's really the equivalent if one of
them lived in LA and one of them lived
in New York if they're doing New York
and La yeah six hours five hours yeah
okay good good I'm happy for you next
story Dancing with the Stars is Dancing
with Stars and the stars are dancing the
stars are still dancing which was crazy
I was on one of their Instagrams last
night to see if she had posted anything
and her whole feed was dancing with the
stars and I was like one of the dancers
one of the Stars oh who Ariana
Maddox she's very vocal vocal I didn't
it was just her whole thing was dancing
with the stars I was like this is still
happening W you know it's so crazy maybe
like we're too in it but like I can't
believe people are literally doing
anything I mean it's crazy um like and
no and like you're not going to cancel
Dancing with the Stars because like
come but um it was just so weird to see
stories were like so many slides of like
dancing dancing dancing pouette kickball
change all this crap all I was like wow
I I'm just like on a different Universe
speaking of Dancing With the Stars you
know me like I am a sleuth I am a
curious cat like when people are doing
fundraisers on Instagram like I'm seeing
which of the people I follow have
donated Harry JY donating $1,000 to the
cause we stand vote for Harry JY vote
for Harry JY and Mauricio y yansy right
because Mauricio yansky declared that he
was dancing for Israel after performing
the fox shot with his partner Emma
Slater on mtown night no I love him
dance to the pop song working my way
back to you and um he said tonight I
stood by Israel and I danced for Israel
and we gave it our all his routine
scored 23 out of 40 points um like why
is this making me cry this is so stupid
dancing like I can't I love Mauricio I
take back every bad thing I've ever said
about him he's my Jewish King he's
always you you know what like he's
always used his very small role on
housewives Kyle too like talking about
their you know Interfaith marriage and
her conversion and Shabbat raising
Jewish daughters I love them I love them
I'm sorry love them he's always been
like a very good representation of a
Jewish man yeah especially cuz there's
so many misconceptions about Judaism I
feel like we had this conversation when
there was like a spike in in
anti-Semitism like a year ago um because
a lot of people who don't care to learn
about the faith like really just dismiss
Jewish people as white and it's so not
true Judaism is an ethn religion and I
think what's going on in Israel is a
testament to that like there are
Lebanese Jews there are um Arab Jews
like most of the Jewish population lives
in Israel over half and they are not
white yeah they're I guess Brown and
Mauricio is a testament he's a Mexican
Jew like you Ethiopian Jews of course
they're black Jews and Maurice is just a
testament to that cuz he is a Mexican
Jew and people I think
who who don't know the complexities of
the religion would say that's impossible
to be a Mexican Jew but it's entirely
possible and you're right he's been a
fabulous representation for our people
and I think we need to remember that
more and then I think there's also a lot
of really public Jews who you know most
days are really great representations of
the people but in times like this they
[__] suck Seth Rogan like literally
never hated someone so much in my
goddamn life what he do what didn't he
do like he's the worst we don't claim
him so to not only see that he's like a
good Jewish man but he supports Israel
and he's not backing down it he's the
whole package and then there's the other
shtick I think Margot said this in one
of our group chats so shout out counts
like people who love to use like Judaism
and culture for shtick for shtick and
like jokes and like lotas ha like being
a Jew when it's easy and then plat and
they get platforms for that and people
use their statements as resources and
they do nothing and yeah other people
who you know dislike Jews and don't want
to support Jews they use those
statements and they hide behind them
they're like I'm with the Jew I'm with
the Jew who [__] sucks yeah and then
there's other like another subset of
people who are very proudly married to
Jews or like date Jews and be like Oh
Jewish men make the best husband and we
all know that and they love to advocate
for the Jud Jewish people like as in a
joke like that's why I was I I had seen
that video of Alex Cooper that went
viral being like first thing my mom told
me was like D I wish my mom told me I
wish my mom told me to a Jewish man and
it went really viral and then when this
was happening you know my ass flocked to
her page she posted she you can't be
with us when it's funny when it's like
nice and fun for you but you have to
also stand with us during the hard times
so yeah I'm I'm just taking notes there
are also women who date Jewish men or
convert and marry Jewish men and have
Jewish children who are the best
advocates for the Jewish Community they
always say the Jewish converts are
better than the Jews like they have such
a um I don't even know what the word is
like ruach is the word like which
translates a spirit but but it's like
this fiery [__] need they are more
observant than you know people who are
born Jewish they are you're right like
converted Jews have this crazy energy in
a good way yeah yeah so it's it's a
spectrum you guys totally and just cuz
someone's Jewish and they said something
like doesn't mean that that's the right
thing like Ben plat statement like crap
throw it in the garbage light it on
fire goodbye bye also someone who used
to be like that but who has stepped his
[__] up is Andy Cohen let's talk about
Andy Cohen I'm so glad you brought that
up um he used to be the worst like
whenever there was like spikes and
anti-Semitism talk about somebody who
was a bigger the biggest platform and
he's not shouting into an echo chamber I
think a lot of creators who are very
proudly Jewish and pro-israel their
followers are the same you know so it's
great but it's not really moving the
needle because you're just shouting into
an echo chamber I mean talk about Andy
Cohen like could he be friends with more
celebrities of different backgrounds
could he have a wider audience like all
over the country from House wives and
and talk about somebody who's literally
done nothing like for the people or the
movement like oh like I it it has
definitely marred my view of him over
the last couple of years because he
really for a very very very very very
long time was like an enormous role
model of mine yeah but also talk about
someone who not only has the audience
and the celebrities in the connections
but whock is so Jewish mael everything
yeah no so who has built a brand with
the Jewish humor and the Jewish culture
but and it it has been enormously
disappointing in recent years but you're
right he has stepped his [__] up like
usually like when some when there's a
spike it takes him a few days and then
he like posts like a week Instagram
story and that's it this time he posted
in feed Y and he was on a was very clear
it's isra flat very clear that's all it
needs to say and you know what I I I do
imagine that some of the influence I
have to imagine Anderson Cooper has
influence him Anderson Cooper has been
fabulous like I watched a bunch of his
segments interviewing Israelis on the
ground interviewing um friends and
family of people he's in Israel he has
been for a few days crying on air like
really I have to imagine Anderson had
impact on Andy cuz you know they're or
Andy had an impact on Anderson true true
true great yep our next story random as
[__] Yellowstone's Cole Hower launches a
new coffee line inspired by his Cowboy
Roots well before we promote his coffee
what did he post no I'm kidding let's
just like make sure that he like I'm
tring
tring it's no it's fine like no he's not
someone that like I need to hear from
you know because I don't hear from him
ever I wouldn't be surprised if he
doesn't have an Instagram no he does
have an Instagram I follow him and so I
would have seen
what what do you post oh no no no sorry
it's
um something from September but it was
like a group of people he like never
posts um but he's very like ha America
which I feel like those people are proar
so oh yeah he was posting like um
September 11 tributes right right HOA
America he's giving ho-ha America like
with a beard I I I would Mark him as
safe if I had to guess like if I was a
bing woman I think he'd be okay yes so
um he's bringing his ranch life
lifestyle to breakfasts everywhere can't
wait to support on Wednesday the actor
who plays rip on Yellowstone I'm sorry
rip launches free rain Coffee Company
people can reveal exclusively how
exciting for people I don't really feel
like that was a people exclusive like I
heard about it like weeks ago I'm so
happy for you people that you could
reveal that exclusively you do some more
coverage about
Israel my God the new brand is meant to
be a nod to the rugged Spirit of the
West and pay tribute to the hardworking
Cowboys that Hower grew up around on and
off ET like I said haa America you know
what I feel like he is a cowboy on TV
and like then we've all started
following him and he's like a cowboy in
real life I feel like there could be
like a scandal about him where he grew
up in New England yeah where it's like
he's not a cowboy like he went to
boarding school and he's like uh putting
on this role and appropriating cowboy
culture because like that's what people
want to see from him okay this is like
totally random I'm like sitting here
thinking like I'm literally embarrassed
that I cried about Taylor's webs like I
need a grip like I'm not okay it's we
cut that out no the thing I'm just
really emotional it's always the most
random things that get you like and I
feel and I if anybody ever clipped that
like I would die of humiliation just if
they if you clip that like clip this
part too where she said she's
embarrassed yeah like am I okay but I
feel like other things that we prepare
ourselves for to talk about on the show
like we got our tears out about the
babies yesterday like and I we knew it
was going to come up today and like you
can prepare yourself yeah and then
something just hits you sideways yeah no
I'm humilated that's like what I said at
the deer toasters last week when she was
crying about the bill that she like had
to you're right and I made fun of her
yeah like no I'm a different person this
week like you will this is a new tury a
nerdy anyways Cole Houser who still
seems to be a cowboy has six Blends that
each cater to different tastes no be
right I'm ready for the kouser
documentary hash kouser is over
party no no no rip rip rip rip no I'm
ready for it like you're right so
inauthentic no I'm saying maybe it's not
unauthentic but I could you see a world
in like he's the Rachel doas all of the
cowboy world I agree I could see it I
could see it but for now I feel like the
only person who talks about Rachel dool
anymore is Joey kasta he like never lets
it go and I think as a society we need
to talk about it more that was crazy
yeah but also she's like an adjective
now like anybody who's like you got
Rachel do isol who's like pretending to
be someone they're not someone they're
not or like from a culture that they're
not is Rachel my mind she pretended to
be black and made her way up to the
president of the NAACP yes she had a big
role at the NAACP at like um she like
braid her hair and stuff yeah and like a
lot of self tanner and then how did
people find out that she was actually
just not black at all I don't know but
that's what people do that's where
people really are the best like that was
sorry I was talking about people who
exposed her not Rachel dool um and it's
like araria that was crazy too yeah that
was
crazy but yeah but yaria wasn't working
at the center for you know Latin life no
and it was just like funny and weird and
like embarrassing weird and embarrassing
but it was like deeply problematic
because you worked at the NAACP yeah
that was crazy crazy times let's start
we need to start talking about Rachel
doas we need a list of Rachel doas alls
yes yes comment below oh whoopy Goldberg
being a Jew yeah but like not at all no
she's not a Jew she just changed her
name and like tells people she's Jewish
Rachel DOL is all it's giving Rachel
dool actually I've been where's whoopy
been another thing buoying me
than Annie like for real me and Ben we
got home from the rally maybe at 6:30 we
ate Chinese food and we sat in bed in
dead silence and scrolled our phones
till 10 o00 you just can't go to bed
after that like so we watch two episodes
of The Nanny it's a show like that is so
proudly Jewish like it's alling the
invitation are halfway to Israel already
like they just like talk about Israel as
it's just it's really be it's it's
buying me and it's an actually funny
show wait where's where's
friender I'm sure she's doing something
because she's a vocal Queen about
everything yeah let me just double check
like yeah no no I I have faith but let's
see she hasn't posted since October 4th
I don't think she has like a constant
stream of Instagram stories goes down in
the stories it goes down in the stories
I agree that was FR Dress Your Story we
need like what are those things called
um a Google do no no no those advocacy
groups they're like watch groups watch
dogs or something okay that like keeps a
running list that just like they keep
tabs on stuff
we also like we really need to talk
about the posting and deleting like it's
running rampant I can't believe people
haven't learned I
know let's
see I doubt Fran Jer has posted anything
like her Instagram is not a reflection
of her like streams of Consciousness no
she hasn't been in the news since July
oh with the word Israel let me take that
out oh yeah yeah yeah because whatever
you're going to find is going to be
about sag because she's a president of
sagra variety to hold Hollywood Summit
on anti-em oh you're a part of this
Mark Mar she's doing that and Claud as
is my name in the headline no but I
added it because you'll be there yes
what fabulous timing for real yeah much
needed this thing was all I'm going to
La next week for it and Fran is like the
keynote speaker and I asked the
organizers I'm like you have to let me
get a picture with Fran why are you in
the text of this article I don't know
actually I did get a media alert I think
I am in like the very bottom if you want
to keep scrolling all the way down no I
scroll no no I'm there I know I am no
for real give me the [__] iPad I yeah
literally
Claudia oh wait oh sorry I don't know
this website the variety the official
one so obviously this website cut me out
what website is it called I don't want
to say it let me
see I've never heard of it yeah but I'm
in it okay everybody eat my
ass um so make sure to check out Cole
Houser's coffee happy for you today's
episode is brought to you by the farmer
dog the farmer dog makes into delivers
fresh and healthy dog food it's
developed by by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and made from real healthy
ingredients to human fa food safety
conditions it's the best option for dogs
at all life stages because it's not
kibble and it's not canned crap it's
healthy real food traditional dog and
wet dry food that we all know are very
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and they are extremely difficult to
proportion accurately the farmer's dogs
so it's just not fresh and healthy dog
food even though it is they also are
sending the food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique traditional based on their unique
needs so when you sign up you'll answer
a ton of questions about your dog's
health habits so many things about the
breed and they're basically tailoring a
very fancy perfectly made diet for your
dog and there are so many healthy
benefits when you switch from processed
food to fresh healthy dog food from the
farmer's dog for Theo when we switched
one of my main issues was his breath
like I knew it wasn't normal it was so
bad and I'm just like a breath person
his breath is so much better his bowel
movements are more consistent they're
better sizing they're like the same time
every day cuz it's just really just
getting his health in check his coat is
shinier there's just so many benefits I
can't recommend investing in fresh
healthy dog food enough strice Bros are
the most important people in our lives
and we must protect them at all costs
and that starts with what we put in
their body the farmer's dog is a
fabulous option doesn't matter if your
dog is young or old it's always the
right time so get 50% off your first box
of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast plus you're
getting free shipping when you go to
thefarmersdog.com toast so for your 50%
off your first box and free shipping go
to thefarmersdog.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed gut health is a huge thing right
now a staggering 650 million videos are
made about it on Tik Tok and a quick
Google search will yield over 30 Million
results and there's a lot of you know
people saying things and doing things
but seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is a
plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic with
24 strain that has been clinically or
scientifically studied for its benefits
it's free from 14 classes of allergens
so it's peanut free it's gluten gluten-
free it's Sesame free it's soy free it's
dairy free it's shellfish free it's
corn-free how it works is you're taking
two capsules a day on an empty stomach
and it's engineered to survive this is
why seed is different they're engineered
to survive your ex external and internal
environments so their capsule and
capsule via cap safeguards viability
through digestion for a delivery of 100%
of your probiotic to your colon the
outer capsule survives the elegant
barrier to oxygen moisture and heat so
no Refrigeration is necessary so here
are some of the benefits most
importantly your digestive health you
want to make big soft duties take seed
there's also a lot of skin
benefits um they have four specific
strains that have been shown to promotee
healthy skin and reinforce a healthy
skin a healthy gut skin access there's
also a lot of health benefits you can
maintain blood cholesterol levels in the
normal range you can support healthy
intestinal recycling of cholesterol and
bile so if you're interested in any of
that seed is the product for you the
daily ds01 symbiotic is the product for
you if you want to avoid gut Mania head
to the trusted source for symbiotics
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com toast and use code toast
that will get you um 30% off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's a nice big discount so cut
through the gut health noise visit
seed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem 30% off your first month of seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic so again that's 30%
off seed seed.com toast seed.com
for 30% off your first month of seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic and our next story
just is going to take us back to a
simpler time thank you the Coast Guard
recovers tit Titan sub wreckage and more
presumed human remains oh God 1600 ft
from the Titanic which was the
submersible destination when it imploded
saw it how much is, 1600 feet how many
feet is a mile 1600 is 16 rulers 1600
rulers not 16 rulers you know I know but
that's hard for me to no that's a lot of
rulers yeah no they wouldn't have seen
it no unless they drifted and they
happened to have been closer before yeah
but I don't think it me means that they
made made it down there especially
because when they heard
the they they said that it collapsed
almost immediately like yeah and the
Coast Guard heard it that was also
[__] sus yeah sussy story sussy
Licious additional presume human Susy
space Act and the final pieces of the
doomed Titan submersible were plucked
from the depths of the Atlantic Ocean
last week I guess this officially
concludes this story Marine safety
Engineers for the Coast Guard recovered
several parts of the wreckage including
the 22t vessels intact titanium enca
from the oce floor on Wednesday but when
they were searching the ocean floor for
like a bunch of days and pretending to
us like they didn't know anything when
they clearly did they didn't look, 1600
feet away and see this end cap right I I
had heard they were searching for Miles
right and according to my math 1600 feet
is less than a mile sussy SpaceX no this
whole situation was so weird remember
when it was like all we were talking
about it honestly I really miss those
days even though it was such a terrible
story but it was a simpler time it was a
simpler time there was no you know real
villain except for that CEO yeah and we
all agreed and we and miss those days of
unity it's like the Su that's what I
thought when you were starting the story
I thought you were talking about the Su
I'm like wait what's the Titan and then
I remember I've moved on from the Suz I
have too I actually moved on pretty
quickly the Su no longer buoys me no the
sus no longer Services me like serves me
it was just it was a moment in time and
and people tried to make it more than
that and it really wasn't and now they
get like stuck looking for attention
yeah oh my God everybody's always going
to the SE with their big boats these
days like they're like
it's a little tight oh no what did I do
look like everybody's being like
attention-seeking hores yeah I guess if
I were a ship captain like wanting to go
viral I'd give it a shot in the Su I
know and I feel like so much of the ship
captain life is like Lonesome and boring
and you know what if they need this to
like stimulate themselves I actually
I'll give them the attention they want
oopsies I made a whoopsie in my
[Music]
pants Oh no me
Kaka I me Kaka in the
bed Kaka in the bed our fifth and final
story yeah it's Amazon Prime day who
cares what are you getting Prime day
2023 continu has Amazon released a
statement with amazing deals Jeff Bezos
like where's he slinging his coin that's
so true but he also owns the Washington
Post which sus sucks ass literally like
oh that's amazing point I don't know but
but I you feel like when you're at that
level like you just own stuff you know
what I mean like I don't think you're
part of the editorial team yeah and you
don't deal with the not that I'm
excusing it but if you do have like
things that you care about you would
make an effort you would make an effort
yeah what about Lauren she's I could see
her being like a pro Israel Queen yeah
me too and she clearly doesn't give a
[__] what people think about her she's
stting je bis no and like she just like
does her thing yeah know when you're at
that level like you she actually it
posts
yeah what does she say and it's also
crazy how all these people who like uh
philanthropy and service is kind of
their brand because they just have money
and nothing else to do like are silent
like the um who are you referring to
Megan and Harry yeah
humanitarian pH and they're out here
talking about mental health today today
yeah it's like world mental health
appreciation day like oh my God those
days help nobody like I think it's
important that we all acknowledge that
is that people never also shout out to
toast sponsor betterhelp who's offering
free therapy to everyone in Israel for
the atrocities they've had to witness
over the last few days proud of proud to
be a a Show sponsored by better help not
today but just in general yeah hold on
she's the vice chair of Bezos Earth fund
did she post anything she has three
stories right now but it's been a while
right in feed no I think she went to
that YouTu concert and the big sphere
sphere yeah the sphere that was covered
in Israeli flag and YouTube performed
and sing a song in solidarity with
Israel I love Vegas can't wait to
return she posted this like but it's
it's it's
unclear you want to know the most
telling thing it's a tweet from someone
from a pastor you want to know the most
telling thing about how much power
social media has on people it's that
people who've never supported a thing in
your life will weaponize responses like
unfollowed as if that's supposed to hurt
you you could have left without an
announcement okay that is go either
could go either way but let's see what
in happening on both sides let's see
what this pastor has been
posting nothing well things about of
course you know having Christ in your
life but
not he spoke at the Jewish Federation of
Greater Philadelphia two month two days
ago okay that's good it's so funny the
way we have to research like but with
you just have to like know where people
stand like because I don't want to like
talk about or follow people who support
evil that's just like not what I want to
do and then she posted another thing we
love your big feelings yeah that's like
mental healthy okay because it's I think
today I'm sorry talking about mental
health given what's going on is a
scapegoat like you seeing influencers
being like mental health is of utmost
important right now mental health is
always of utmost important to worry
about your mental health it's actually a
privilege when you don't have your
physical health like look at this
headline from people today Megan marle
stuns in an off the white shoulder
Ensemble on October 10th at the archwell
foundation parents Summit titled mental
Wellness in the digital age during
Project Healthy Minds World mental
health Day Festival in New York no
that's first of all trim it down trim it
down it's just journalism 101 so today's
world mental health
day I'm sorry I just feel like when
things become days like International
women's day things when you become a day
the cause is over like I because to me
it helps nobody it almost trivializes
what the thing is about and it makes me
feel stupid being a women a woman on
International women's day like for real
yeah World mental health
day and if you're going to have like a
summit about motherhood and kids and
like you don't acknowledge what's going
on right now like you're a joke yeah and
it's not a funny one pass me the iPad we
s your toasters do we want to do that
today I feel like it'll it'll lift
Spirits time have
time okay so dear toasters our uh what
is it weekly advice segment is where you
guys can write into to us about what
you're currently dealing with and we'll
do our best to give you advice it's all
Anonymous you can email us de toasters
gmail.com or you can head over to the
toast podcast.com and submit it there
too
so are you ready mhm actually I want to
start with this one that I saw earlier
was like giving it was like
giggly okay hi Claud and Jax I'm a grown
woman marrying a grown man he just so
happens to be providing me an
opportunity as our therapist says to
temporarily be living with his parents
before we buy our home oh before we buy
their home oh that was an important
thing I misread so I guess they're
moving or whatever they're going to buy
the house from the parents with this
comes a ple plethora of issues with the
future in-laws I've learned to not get
mad but rather just laugh yesterday my
future mother-in-law took the liberty to
fold my clothes from the dryer I could
understand if I was hogging valuable
real estate but she wasn't even doing
laundry my fiance says she was just my
fiance says she was just being nice but
I surmised she wanted to see my
undergarments is this weird am I in the
wrong I think she's being nice like
honestly anybody would F my laundry like
no seriously I don't care best friend I
don't care if you're a Hamas terrorist
like you're folding my laundry no I'm
totally kidding um anyone who folds
anyone's laundry I understand like
taking it out putting it in a laundry
basket because you need the dryer that's
different and I don't think that's rude
either no stay on top of your [__] like
but to fold it like that's actually nice
maybe she sees you I wouldn't I I unless
she's like a deeply evil person who you
have like crazy evil history with which
if you live with I don't assume that you
have that um I I think you can uh assume
that her intentions are good give her
the benefit of the doubt and just take
the folded laundry and take the win yeah
no I I hate to say a toaster is in the
wrong because toaster are never in the
wrong she's asking people just assume
they're right and they're like what do I
do and it's like uh how do we tell you
tell you the call is coming from inside
the house that's another okay wait we
need to start a list there's this woman
on Tik Tok who like stitches people's
videos who use like funny phrases and
writes them down she's like I want to
start adding these to my daily life and
there are a few things like I I always
want to start saying more Rachel doall
okay the call is coming from inside the
house just like good terms good [__]
like a list of good [__] no my my list
titles like have to be really specific
or else I can't find them okay um list
of phrases terms and phrases terms and
phrases you've been Rachel dozal no no
no you are Rachel like they areel well
you can it's a noun or verb that's
what's so beautiful about it but when
let's say like you've been Rachel Do's
house it's like that happened to you not
you did it yourself let me just write
Rachel DOL on we can iron out the terms
later yeah yeah yeah or like the
specificities the call is coming from
inside the house whenever people use
that phrase I it makes me giggle it's so
funny it's like you're being
hypocritical yeah okay do we have
anything else that like oh the Game of
Thrones thing you said earlier today oh
we all have a role to play in the war to
come is that it yep I like that
one obviously for me [__] around and
find out yeah but that one that one
comes to mind a lot I don't I don't
forget it I don't find these naturally
coming to mind and it bothers me okay so
we'll keep the list going okay great
dear Jackson Claude Avid listener and
Spritz Enthusiast here I'll try to keep
this short my husband and I have been
married for 6 years and we had our
second child 2 months ago I've been a
size four my whole life but after our
second I've really struggle to lose the
pregnancy weight I'm now a size eight
since I've added on weight my husband
orders for me every time we are out
eating and has never done so in the past
he will only order salads or something
very healthy while he orders whatever he
wants and I'm starving should I be happy
he's trying to help or mad because he
won't let a breastfeeding Mama eat what
would you do please help oh Jackie was
had a different thought until no I
didn't oh like your head ticked over
breastfeeding yeah I didn't realize she
was still breastfeeding so that's
different she needs to get those extra
500 calories no honestly and you're
[__] ravenous when you're this is
beyond problematic Behavior like your
husband should be canceled like no I
know and it's like it's one thing if he
wants to like say something to you
straight up but to be so manipul
manipulative it makes it worse no and
honestly like a man who has anything to
say about like his wife's body like
problematic but it takes it to another
level when she's postpartum literally
like just gave you two children the
second child is two months old no that's
crazy this man's a problem but the thing
is she has two kids with him and
especially two Monon old so she's got
solve this yeah know and I'm sure she's
writing in because she's probably still
really hormonal and she's like am I
crazy I mean I think you guys should
have a conversation about it where
you're like you need to stop I just gave
birth two months ago I understand I'm
not who I was when you married me and if
that and I might never be and I might
never be or if that's something that
like is important to you you could be
like just be patient with me like I'll
get there and if you don't intend on
getting there which is also fine just be
like and this is who I am now because I
gave you two children like [__] deal
with it [__] [__] all the way off [__]
all the way off ordering for me no or by
the way we don't talk enough as a
society about the types of people in our
society who order for others yeah but
also say like you're starving our child
if I don't get enough calories yeah
you're starving our child people who
order for other people like I that's
like one of my biggest like um etiquette
pet peeves like it's so presumptuous
yeah especially these days everyone has
like allergies dietary preferences
gluten intolerances you literally can't
order for someone else no it's like a
crazy thing to do mhm all right are you
ready for our third yes hey Jackson TTY
hope you can give me some advice my
husband and I have been together for
almost 13 years married for five and we
have a 2-year-old son together two years
into dating when I was 18 and he he was
20 Scandal I found out from a friend
that he had cheated on me it was a
drunken one night stand I broke it off
and about a year later we reconnected
and then the rest is history out of
nowhere this whole situation has found
its way back into my mind and I just
can't get past it I told him how I was
feeling and it made me feel it made him
feel really awful and it's now just
become this like big elephant in the
room he suggested having a loone time
going on a date but I'm just not into it
what do I do honestly I feel like this
is like the time for couples
counseling like getting through
infidelity is really hard and it's like
once you get over it like what what it
takes like a year like it can come back
I didn't know that yeah I mean how can
you not be resentful yeah but I I
thought once forgive in the words of
Lauren but you you can't forget no but I
feel like once you move past it you're
past it I didn't realize it could like
have flare-ups it can have flare-ups but
like the rule and this is what I think
they say in couples counseling the rule
and by the way I sound like I'm speaking
from experience and like I'm not I don't
know where I hear this I feel like I
heard it in um the sweetest no no what's
that movie uh how to lose Guy in 10 Days
when she dresses up as a therapist as a
therapist who looks like G Lions um they
say like you you work it out like you
you can be mad but once it's done like
you're not allowed that's like here lies
Shannon Shannon and D here lies Shannon
yes Shannon and David Mador she had to
literally bury her former self in order
to move on from their Affair so it's
like a big no no to move on and then
like come back but it's a human instinct
right so I think counseling is a great
solution I know and I think people think
couples counseling like is the beginning
of the end but I know a lot of people
who are in like extremely healthy
marriages who go all the time like who
don't even have problems like they just
like go yeah and I'm not talking about
myself even though I sound like I am but
I wouldn't be embarrassed if I was I
think every couple's different every
person's different some people do a lot
of therapy and want to do therapy even
when they're mentally sound and other
people even when they're un they're
mentally unwell they don't go to therapy
everyone's different I think that's a
really good um solution also for me
sometimes I just need time like this
like I'll get over it in my like I just
know especially if they've worked
through it it's like oh I'm having a
flare up right now like something else
will come up in a few weeks and I know
it won't bother me that give me anxiety
and something else to worry about yeah
yeah yeah I also find like maybe when
you experience like temporary eras of
peace in your life like where nothing's
bothering you you go tend to go back and
find things self-sabotage find things to
worry about like maybe this is to look
at it with a positive maybe you're just
in like a very peaceful place in your
life that you're looking for things to
worry about yeah I think we've all been
there yeah but I don't think like you
need to break up with him immediately I
would try a few things before you do
something like that I think it can be
remedied if it can't then it can't but I
think it can be same and those were de
toasters I'm so glad we were able to
help others that's what today do so
that's our
show yeah that will always be our show
hopefully um when we go back on our
phones after this
there's not horrible news waiting for us
my phone's blowing up so thank you to
everyone for being here and we love you
dearly have a great day love you bye
bye